this episode of real engineering was
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 16,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill the first 500 people a
sign up with the link in the description
will get a 2 month free trial on October
15 1997 trust SSC became the first land
vehicle to break the sound barrier
breaking the land speed record with an
astonishing top speed of one thousand
two hundred and twenty eight kilometers
per hour which still stands today twenty
years on and the team that created this
wonder of engineering is now looking to
break their own record with the new and
improved Bloodhound SSC a vehicle
looking to achieve an amazing milestone
of one thousand miles per hour or 1609
kilometers per hour for those of us
living in the civilized world creating a
land vehicle capable of achieving these
speeds presents some very unique
engineering challenges and today we're
going to explore a problem that even
limits the top speed of the Bugatti
Chiron how to design a wheel capable of
withstanding the extreme forces at these
speeds when designing a high speed carry
there are two problems of physics that
grow disproportionately the faster you
travel first the drive force to vehicle
experiences grows with the square of the
speed returned to top speed for every
unit of horsepower included shrinks the
faster you go but that's a problem for a
future video today we're going to
explore the second problem the massive
inertial forces the tire experiences at
higher speed if you watch my video on
artificial gravity you will know that a
spinning Mass will experience an
increase in weight proportional to the
square of the angular velocity
multiplied by the distance from the
rotational Center this phenomenon can be
used to create artificial gravity in
space but put too much weight on the
outside of the spaceship or spin it too
fast and it could tear itself apart the
slow mo guys did an absolutely
mesmerizing test of this when they spawn
a CD up to 23,000 revolutions per minute
before it's shattered under the weight
of its own inertia this effect is one of
the key limiting factors currently
holding cars like the Bugatti Chiron
the Hennessey Venom and the Cohens ago
Gareth from the illustrious milestone of
300 miles per hour just this month the
Agera broke the production speed record
and came the closest to that milestone
with a top speed of two hundred and
seventy seven point nine miles per hour
there isn't a tire on earth that can
withstand the inertial forces at higher
speeds the road
would simply peel away from the hub but
evidently we aren't far off however if
these carrots don't come close to the
speeds of the land speed record held by
trust SSC so what kind of wheel did the
trust SSE use when it demolished the
land speed record all the way back in
1997
well the thrust SSC has one primary
advantage when it comes to wheels it has
very little use for traction beyond
braking and turning as the wheels are
not used to transmit rotational motion
from the engine to linear motion it
achieves its propulsion from jet engines
and rockets
these wheels simply need to support the
7.5 tonne weight of the vehicle and
allow to roll along the ground and have
enough lateral traction to allow the
driver to steer the car at higher speeds
this even becomes unnecessary as the
vehicle gets the majority of its
steering force from the force of air
hitting the angled wheels the Bloodhound
derives its power from the ej200 jet
engine the same used by the eurofighter
typhoon and an even more powerful hybrid
rocket engine at its fastest the wheels
of the Bloodhound will be rotating
10,000 times per minute using that
equation from earlier and with the wheel
radius at 76 point five centimeters we
can calculate that an e mass on the
outside of the rim will experience
50,000 times the acceleration due to
gravity a 1 kilogram bag of sugar would
weigh the same as a fully laden
articulated truck with these problems in
mind let's begin the design process for
our 1,000 mile for our wheels a step 1
is material selection this will
determine a large portion of our design
process as the design will change
according to the material properties and
the manufacturing techniques as
explained before traction is not a huge
concern so we can forego the rubber tire
and instead go for a solid metal wheel
which can better withstand the
centrifugal force caused by the spinning
wheel the metal needs to not only be
strong enough to withstand these forces
but also needs to be light enough to
minimize the inertial force on top of
all this the material needs to be
capable of absorbing damage which is why
a carbon-fiber wheel is not an option as
at these speeds an unexpected hit from a
stone could potentially shatter the
entire wheel if the material is too
brittle these are a very particular set
of requirements that forged aerospace
grade aluminium fulfills best now that
the material has been selected we can
begin forging blanks and to forge these
wheels the team took huge billets of
aluminium alloys 7:03 7 and heated them
to 390 degrees and compress
that would at 3,600 ton forging press
the forging clamp operator here deserves
credit for the insane precision taking
this cylindrical bullet and forming it
into a compressed disc this is our blank
which will be passed to a milling
machine to mill the wheel into its final
shape transforming the cast material
which is the material that was formed by
pouring molten aluminium into a cast
into this forged material makes the
material vastly stronger when the molten
aluminium is cooling the become solid
the crystal structure grows randomly
from nucleation sites like a snowflake
from a single ice crystal this
unpredictable process gives rise to a
random jumble of crystal sizes grain
directions and voids called dislocations
between individual crystal grains when
the solidified cast aluminium is
compressed the crystal grains increase
in density and dislocations pile up
which increases the energy required to
cause expansive deformation this process
is called work hardening and it
drastically increases the strength of
the material but it also makes it less
ductile but that's desirable in this
situation as we do not want the wheel
expanding during use now that we have
our blank material we can begin the
prototyping process we do not want to
use this expensive material and begin
prototyping with it failed designs would
be extremely expensive the team will
first start with some basic design
parameters like wheel diameter they will
then determine the general thickness
needed for vehicle stability and to
withstand the predicted stress using
these parameters a model will be
generated and tested computationally we
performed our own computational analysis
on stress and deformation from inertial
forces on the Bloodhound wheel using sim
scale using a tool like this the
engineers will refine the design once a
suitable design is found prototyping
whether cheaper material will begin many
engineering firms today use treaty
printing for this design verification
step but the Bloodhound team used a
cheap cast aluminium wheel they attached
this wheel to a trailer that simulated
the weight of the bloodhound on a single
axle and it helped them discover that
their wheel did not adequately spread
the load over the desert surface meaning
it was breaking through the crust and
driving on the hard bedrock underneath
which would damage the wheel back to the
drawing board to increase the contact
surface of the wheel this design and
prototyping process will be repeated
until a suitable design is found once
the final design was decided on the
expensive forged aluminium was passed to
a CNC milling machine
which uses computer guidance to cut the
wheel to its final shape however when a
work hardened material is machined it
disrupts the compressive forces that
developed in the skin during the forging
process the surface of the machined
metal is like a bottle of compressed air
and a small leak may lead to an
explosion it wants to expand so if a
crack forms in the surface of this
material these expansive forces will
increase the chances of that crack
growing and so another surface treatment
called shot peening is applied by
shooting thousands of tiny spherical
balls at the surface of the machined
product to introduce a thin layer of
higher compression which helps the
material resist crack growth this final
product was sent for design verification
again where it was rotated up to speed
and a controlled environment to ensure
it would safely take this astounding
vehicle to one point three times the
speed of sound just two months ago the
Bloodhound SSC completed a 200 mile per
hour test at Cornwall Airport the
Bloodhound reached this top speed in
just eight seconds with a zero to 60
speed of just two seconds that's a half
second faster than the bugatti chiron
this run serves to test the Eurofighter
Typhoon engine and to demonstrate the
vehicle to the public after all the goal
is not to break the record they already
have the record with the trust SSC the
real goal here is to inspire people to
get excited about engineering which I
can wholeheartedly get behind sharing
passion and skill is something this
channel was founded on and today I want
to share with you a fantastic course on
Skillshare that teaches you one of the
most important skills in the world
storytelling with this channel I didn't
want to be another Science Channel
explaining science without any real
context the magic in the world of
engineering lies in the motivations of
the engineers and to share their story I
had to learn how to tell a compelling
story and this is a skill that will
serve you in so many walks in life
sharing the story of your company can
bring it to new heights and that's what
keeps Yamashita whose course I am
recommending today has done with
companies like Apple General Electric
and eBay in this course Keith walks you
through the components of a great story
and the methods of composing and
refining a story the first 500 people
are sign up to skill share with this
link we'll get a 2 month free trial to
watch this or any number of the other
17,000 classes in subjects that range
from graphic design to game development
a premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all
courses button though
three two months you could easily learn
the skills you need to start a new hobby
or business just like I did with this
channel so ask yourself right now what
skill have you been putting off learning
what project have you been dreaming of
completing but you aren't sure if you
have the skills to do it why not start
right now and sign up to skill share
using the link below you've nothing to
lose on a valuable life skill to gain as
usual thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links from
my Instagram Facebook and Twitter
profiles are below